[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminio fernández y hoy los
llevaremos a eeuu comenzamos los
economistas lo llaman the great lakes
ignition o la gran renuncia un
movimiento que describe un fenómeno sin
precedentes se trata de una ola masiva
de trabajadores que han dejado sus
trabajos en noviembre del año pasado la
cifra de estas personas que renunciaron
se ubicó en 4.5 millones las renuncias
no han parado desde el comienzo de la
pandemia de kobe 19 y entre las razones
se cuentan renuncias postergadas
agotamiento laboral y el auge del
trabajo remoto entre otros el sector más
afectado ha sido la industria hotelera
seguida por el entretenimiento el
comercio minorista y los servicios de
salud también se han producido huelgas
importantes en todo el país con
trabajadores exigiendo salarios más
altos y mejores condiciones de trabajo
empleadores y empleados en eeuu se
encuentran en un equilibrio de poder que
está pasando en el país del capitalismo
a continuación el reportaje de fania lar
[Música]
bocinazos de solidaridad para los
obreros de la fábrica de que lux
desde hace dos meses los 1400 empleados
de las cuatro plantas del gigante de los
cereales están en huelga
aquí en tennessee se reúnen día y noche
delante de la empresa para exigir
mejores condiciones de trabajo para
todos los empleados
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]
y
su empeño por luchar y decirle que no a
que los inspira a los trabajadores del
país es la mejor manera de animarlos
para que ellos también luchar los
empleados de kellogg's protestan contra
un sistema de remuneración con dos
niveles que perjudica a los nuevos
empleados quienes reciben un salario de
18 dólares la hora mientras que a los
más antiguos se les paga 30 para kevin
bracho obrero y representante sindical
el kobe despertó la solidaridad la
empresa ganó más de 380 millones de
dólares en nueve meses y obtuvo un 158
por ciento de bonificaciones mientras
que nosotros sólo recibimos una
bonificación de 500 dólares por haber
arriesgado nuestras vidas trabajamos
durante toda la pandemia sin parar sin
días más ligeros nos decían que éramos
unos héroes y ahora nos tratan como si
fuéramos menos que nada pero el cubit
despertó a los trabajadores que ahora se
están dando cuenta de que han trabajado
y se han sacrificado para enriquecer a
esas empresas todos los días sin pedir
mucho a cambio una de las
reivindicaciones son horarios de trabajo
decentes porque desde el comienzo de la
pandemia
de cereales explotó en eeuu y los
empleados han trabajado de 12 a 16 horas
diarias los 7 días de la semana
hoy que lo que se les propuso un acuerdo
pero fue rechazado de manera unánime
nosotros los representantes sindicales
apoyamos lo que deciden los trabajadores
y ellos decidieron rechazar esta
propuesta ya basta kellogg's no están
necesitados sólo están tratando de
abusar de nosotros si siguen así
seguiremos en huelga cada día que pasa
es un día más en el que somos más
fuertes que ellos kevin trabaja en
kellogg's desde hace 20 años está a
cargo del embalaje de los cereales antes
de su distribución
este es el departamento de recepción y
expedición para presionar a sus
empleados que lo que se está amenazando
con reemplazarlos con reubicar sus
operaciones si la huelga no se acaba
pero según kevin esa estrategia para
generar miedo ya no funciona saben que
no pueden funcionar sin nosotros que los
existen gracias a nosotros porque
nosotros somos que los en este momento
tienen trabajadores a los que les da
igual estar ahí son personas que no
pueden mantener las personas están
renunciando de la noche a la mañana y
ellos creen que pueden presionar nos
amenazando con reemplazo después de tres
meses de huelga se llegó a un acuerdo
entre que lo que sus empleados una
victoria sindical que le hace eco a
otros movimientos de huelga e inéditos
en el país
el fandi
[Música]
el hobbit 19 transformó el mercado
laboral en todos los sectores los
empleadores tienen dificultades para
contratar personal es el caso de forjar
tot mano gerente de una empresa de
limusinas en memphis
antes de la pandemia tenía seis
conductores para sus 14 vehículos hoy no
tiene ninguno
y
necesita urgentemente conductores pero
no encuentro
y tratando de contratar necesito al
menos tres conductores para mantener mi
actividad actual por eso yo estoy
manejando ahora
mi esposa y yo fácilmente manejamos
entre 90 y 100 horas a la semana diría
que en agosto y septiembre pasado perdí
al menos tres mil dólares por semana
porque estaba obligado a rechazar viajes
además de su empresa de limusinas farhat
es el gerente de este café en el centro
de la ciudad
aquí la contratación tampoco es fácil el
establecimiento funciona gracias a una
sola mesera y al propio jefe
flaca
juande
nunca me habría imaginado que estaría
preparando yo mismo las bebidas cuando
abrí este café en los primeros años
no es así como me imaginaba la situación
pero con la pandemia y la falta de
trabajadores estoy obligado a hacer lo
que sea necesario para cuidar a los
clientes y cuidar médicos
esta mañana farhat entrevista a un
hombre joven que está dudando entre dos
ofertas de empleo para asegurarse de que
hacer del trabajo farhat está dispuesto
a pagarle más de 7,25 dólares la hora el
salario mínimo en tennessee
recibirás un pago por horas cada dos
semanas a cuánto me va a pagar la hora y
puedo empezar en 8,5 dólares la hora más
las propinas si trabajas en las mañanas
fácilmente podrás ganar un promedio de
1920 dólares la hora y a partir de ahí
si te quedas conmigo de aumentar la
tarifa realmente quiero que trabajes con
nosotros hasta principios de septiembre
los desempleados recibían una ayuda
federal de 300 dólares a la semana para
apoyar a la población afectada por el
comió pero tennessee al igual que otros
25 estados puso fin a estas ayudas en
junio con la esperanza de que así los
estadounidenses volvieran al trabajo sin
embargo las cifras no indican que haya
habido una retoma significativa del
empleo en noviembre cuatro millones y
medio de estadounidenses abandonaron su
puesto de trabajo una cifra histórica en
20 años
y creo que las personas están tomando
conciencia de que su tiempo es valioso
por ejemplo yo renuncié a un trabajo
seis meses después del comienzo de la
pandemia no era muy gratificante no me
gustaba a mí me encanta trabajar en
comunidad como en los cafés claro no me
gano también la vida pero estoy mucho
más contento que una oficina todo el día
ese también es el caso de personas que
trabajan en la cadena de comida rápida y
piensan que vale mucho más que eso
tienen el derecho de poder hacer algo
que les guste
al igual que nick los trabajadores
estadounidenses parecen haber cambiado
sus prioridades en particular en el caso
de las familias el cierre de los
colegios al principio de la pandemia
obligó a muchos padres a adaptarse y
cambiar su estilo de vida elisabeth not
in game sort of onís está de profesión
madre de tres hijos renunció en junio de
2020 para darles clase ella misma porque
no lograban adaptarse a la enseñanza
virtual
es un trabajo en constante evolución
cuando empezamos realmente no teníamos
otra opción porque todo había cerrado y
de repente los niños estaban en la casa
así que al principio traté de ser muy
estricta y académica
a las nueve matemáticas a las diez
recreo a las once ciencias
eso funciona un tiempo y luego
evolucionamos hacia nuestra propia
manera de hacer las cosas más natural
renunciar no fue una decisión fácil para
esta mujer que trabajó toda su vida
ahora el hogar depende únicamente de los
ingresos del padre de familia pero la
pareja decidió seguir con este sistema
educativo a pesar de la reapertura de
los establecimientos escolares y
privilegiando el bienestar familiar
frente a la comunidad financiera a
seguir con la educación en casa este año
fue una buena decisión para nosotros nos
permite tener el control todo sigue muy
incierto no sabemos si los colegios
volverán a cerrar y se retomará la
enseñanza virtual
además antes del convite éramos una
familia muy ocupada corríamos a todas
partes los niños estaban en el bus a las
7 30 de la mañana nos apresurábamos para
ir a la oficina y luego para regresar a
la casa hacer las tareas ir a las clases
de deporte hacer la senda hemos
desacelerado el ritmo y ahora la
prioridad realmente se volvió la salud y
la seguridad de nuestros hijos y de
nuestra familia ya no podemos volver a
nuestro antiguo estilo de vida
un punto de vista que los hijos de
elisabeth también comparten porque no
quieren volver al colegio público
me gusta la flexibilidad que da el
colegio en casa algunos días no hago
nada si no tengo ganas y otros días
trabajo mucho
además recibo más atención individual
que en el colegio donde hay otros 20
alumnos en clase
antes del 2020 un poco más del 5 el 54
por ciento de las familias
estadounidenses afirmaban seguir el
modelo de la enseñanza en casa tras casi
dos años de pandemia esta cifra se ha
duplicado y la familia nottingham ahora
hace parte del 11% de estadounidenses
que optaron por este estilo de vida
elizabeth recibe hoy la visita de una de
sus antiguas colegas karen que no
revirtió su trabajo por miedo a no poder
mantenerse económicamente las dos
mujeres no se habían visto desde el
comienzo de la pandemia
cómo te ha ido con la enseñanza en casa
ha sido un reto pero va bien
y lo más duro para mí ha sido sentirme
privada de alguien
antes tenía una carrera tenía una vida
por fuera de estas cuatro paredes
pero fue mi decisión renunciar y sé que
fue lo mejor que pude haber hecho por
los niños y por mí
elisabeth no es la única en haber
renunciado a su puesto de trabajo ocho
de sus antiguos colegas se han ido del
consultorio médico a lo largo de los
últimos meses y ellos también hacen
parte de la gran renuncia
muchas personas se han ido y por razones
totalmente comprensibles pero yo nunca
había visto a tantas personas renunciar
como en el curso de los últimos dos años
a todo el mundo le gusta nuestra empresa
realmente tenemos un buen ambiente de
trabajo y aún así sé que todo el mundo
está pensando en renunciar
a going back por supuesto he pensado en
regresar a mi trabajo también he tenido
algunas ofertas laborales pero no puedo
volver es difícil de explicar no quiero
hacerlo toda mi mentalidad cambio y una
vez que uno ha probado esa libertad es
inimaginable pensar en trabajar para
otra persona
en diciembre 63 millones de
estadounidenses estaban sin trabajo
aunque había más de 10 millones de
vacantes en el país son cifras que
revelan una relación con el trabajo
profundamente transformada en un país
que sin embargo es muy capitalista nos
encontramos con los huelguistas de
kellogg's de memphis
para kevin bracho la gran renuncia es la
prueba de que los trabajadores morfín
tomaron consciencia de su valor
[Música]
pienso que después del hobby todo
dependerá de la manera en la que las
empresas realmente quieren sobrevivir
invirtiendo en sus trabajadores si no se
invierte dinero en los trabajadores y se
priorizan las ganancias antes que las
personas no habrá mano de obra pero los
jefes no quieren compartir las ganancias
las quieren todas para ellos pero al
anteponer las a las personas el
resultado será lo que ya está pasando
ahora personas que no quieren ir a
trabajar no se trata de una escasez de
mano de obra sino de una crisis salarial
el problema no es nuevo pero no puede
continuar ahora más que nunca estoy
cansado de sufrir así es una señal de
alerta y en todas partes los
trabajadores están empezando a
despertarse
[Música]
y
por primera vez en la historia de eeuu
el equilibrio de poder entre empleadores
y empleados se ha invertido
ahora los trabajadores tienen ventaja y
lo reivindican
esta tendencia perfectamente podría
volverse la norma los salarios han
aumentado más del 45 por ciento en 2021
prueba de la fuerte competencia entre
los empleadores por encontrar mano de
obra
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar estas y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]